foreign
we're here with Paul Larson uh Paul tell
me a little bit about your background
and what you do at MSR Microsoft
research
all right let's see now how far back
should I start well as far as relevant
uh I I finished my studies in Finland
and then I came to Canada as a visitor
for one year
after three months they decided they
wanted to make me a permanent faculty
member at the University of Waterloo so
I accept it stayed there for 15 years
and then in 96 I joined a database group
here in Microsoft research
and I've been here ever since
working on various aspects of database
systems which I've actually done
or since early 1980s and you're famous
for inventing a linear hashing algorithm
tell me a bit about that what what is
that for someone who may not know it's a
hash table that as you add elements to
it it automatically grows and the lookup
times and so on stay stable
and can you tell me how have databases
changed throughout the years that you've
been at Microsoft research
surprisingly little surprisingly little
uh the basic architecture almost uh
relational database system goes back to
early 80s
and yes things have been added and
they've added functionality and so on
but the basic underlying architecture
has not changed still the same
and several years ago you collaborated
with the SQL team to create some new
technology called hecaton what was the
motivation for this well the motivation
was that the underlying Hardware
platform had changed a lot over the last
30 years since the basic architecture or
SQL server was designed it had changed
to the point where it was clear that we
couldn't stay with the old architecture
and I hope that that would survive for
another 20 years we had to respond to
among other things very large main
memories and lots of course
and describe what what is hackathon and
uh what makes it significantly different
so hackathon itself is a main memory
database engine
so it it assumes that the tables that
that it manages are stored entirely in
memory
um and it
given given that there are lots of
things that you can simplify compared
with current database systems
so we removed a lot of the overhead that
you have in a traditional database
system they invented a lot of new
algorithms and so on to make use of the
fact to to be able to exploit the fact
that memories these are in memory
and to be able to scale them to very
very large number of processes I mean we
we need to scale to hundreds of
processors
and typically when people think of
scaling something that they want to
throw Hardware at the problem at what
point does more Hardware not benefit and
lead you to redesign how databases are
built you have
throwing Hardware at a problem where you
have inherent with the limitation is
inherent contingent doesn't help so I'll
give you an example
database systems have something called a
lock manager so every time you need to
look at a record you first have to get a
lock on it and that means that you have
to go to a shared data structure
uh this shared data structure has to be
protected because there's a lot of
concurrent activity on it and
that locking and protection of that lock
manager itself now becomes a bottleneck
you can only have so much concurrent
activity on it and that ends up limiting
the throughput that you can get so has
nothing to do with Hardware it doesn't
matter how many cores you throw at it
you're still limited by that you have
some inherent bottlenecks in the
software
so
not much you can do you can throw
Hardware at it but it won't help and so
hackathon is uh based in memory rather
than on disk yes it is it's entirely uh
the data is stored entirely in memory
and it has a number of other Innovative
features one thing for example is that
all data structures are block free or
latch free
which is the best technique that that we
know of to support very high concurrent
access on data structures
handle fault Tolerance on servers with a
database that's entirely in memory two
ways uh
all updates are still logged to
persistent storage whether it be disk or
or solid state disks and so on
uh hackathon is fully integrated into
SQL server and SQL server has a high
availability feature basically you have
replicas of the database
on other machines and on a failure of
the primary the secondary takes over
within seconds
so hackathon is fully integrated with
that
and so tell me about the collaboration
with the SQL team how did that come
about
uh came about because I had been working
with them on something else
which is also in the product and then
they started thinking about well so what
can we do for transactional workloads
can we get something that would go
really really fast for transactional
workloads
that project started and I got involved
with it right away
so I've been working with SQL server for
a long long time
collaboration come about
I think it started pretty much because
we were working together some on the
column store column store yes
and uh uh
well at the time Mike Mike was leading
uh sort of an advanced development
effort
and that group that was a small group
decided to to start looking at what can
we do for oltp
with these new architectures coming in
and what came what do we need
and set very ambitious goals
yeah and what was it with uh SQL that
just couldn't uh move forward that you
had to change well it's it's not just
SQL Server it's kind of
disk optimized database systems in
general share this property so I like to
be clear that it's not SQL Server is
slow it's a SQL Server is optimized for
a different set of Hardware capabilities
and so
um it's it's that it's what it's
optimized for and what it's targeted at
and also I guess the other Trend that
was happening and Paul was instrumental
on that also with the column store
technology is building specialized
engines that are that are optimized for
particular workloads and column stores
are optimized for business intelligence
and data warehousing workloads and
um in talking to Paul early on okay what
could we do that would optimized for
oltp workloads and um and that mindset
that it's okay to optimize different
engines for different workloads and
incorporate them into one product
it was kind of a key what are the types
of scenarios that hackathon shines and
it excels
uh it excels at uh random lookups of
data it excels in workloads that need
very low latency sub millisecond
measured in hundreds of microseconds or
even less
latency to get to look up rows and to
look up data in tables
High contention scenarios when there's
lots of transactions fighting over
a small set of data or data that's
frequently updated and frequently
accessed together while it's being
updated
those are those are kind of course
descriptions if you look at workloads
you think of workloads that do this
online gaming shopping cart maintenance
for
websites
stock trading inventory you know
real-time inventory analysis so that you
can be analyzing your inventory while
it's being rapidly changed
those are some of those ingestion of
very fast ingestion of data that might
be bursty you know a big lump of data is
coming in
um be able to absorb it quickly get it
indexed instantly and available for
Access and so going into the project uh
what were your aspirations as far as
increasing speed and what were the
results
well the aspirations actually originally
we were thinking well maybe we can get
10x but we talked to Paul and others who
really challenged us to think 100 times
faster thus the name hecaton and and the
focus there was about
if you if you think 100 times you
basically have to rethink everything
anything in the path of execution that
the database system is doing is a
potential bottleneck
um at 100 times
so that was the aspiration Force us to
rethink everything we would have been
perfectly happy with 10 right that's
that's great
um but the the four but not settling for
that initially was actually a really
important uh it was important to change
our mindset because it forced us to
rethink we couldn't basically reach into
the tool bag and say well what's the old
solution that we have for this we tweak
it a little bit no we had to rethink
everything right and everything really
is
what were some of your biggest
challenges that you had uh with this
project
it was plenty plenty of them
one thing that I was heavily involved in
so I'll bring that up was uh
how are you going to make sure that you
can have a high highly concurrent access
to data without
much overhead right
uh traditional techniques for main
memory database system just not too much
overhead so we had to rethink that
which we did
so that was challenging
I think another area was um
fairly early on in the project we
developed the core techniques that would
get us 40 50x
it was the integration into SQL Server
that was really hard
for a variety of reasons one is that SQL
Server is a large complex product itself
and to introduce a new engine inside of
it and to incorporate how it works with
the way SQL Server Works was a big
Challenge and the other area is it's a
you know people it's a mission critical
product people use it for their missing
critical systems and so the quality the
reliability all that has to be there and
it has to be there in V1 it can't be
there later because the applications
that want to use this high performance
technology are also usually Mission
critical applications and so
really achieving that the the quality
bar that SQL Server sets
was one of the harder pieces too that
was an incredible amount of work that
the development team has done I mean
that's huge and so uh what what did uh
you and your side of the team bring to
the table what parts were you working on
well I I worked a lot on the concurrency
control and the data structures and that
part of it that really sort of core
storage engine
that's primarily where I where I be
focused and were you working with
customer Partners were you able to get
feedback from people who are actually
using this yeah actually fairly early on
in the project we started looking
um working with customers early on to
get their feedback on our ideas and then
to give them very early versions of the
code to try out and play with and see
what they could achieve with it
get their early feedback and what types
of gains did they see from the beginning
um
well uh one customer that tried it very
very early on went from 15 000
transaction no 15 000 transactions per
second up to 250 250 now I think
initially they saw a hundred and fifty
thousand so about 10x right away 20.
so uh generally it the feedback was yes
it can help us go fast
but we want more features that was uh
the feedback that's been consistent
we're listening to that and trying to
add you know
um to broaden its feature set as much as
uh as we can so right and is that what's
next is that what you're going to be
working on next that certainly is a key
piece of it
um uh broadening the feature set giving
this performance capabilities to a wider
set of applications uh making it easier
for applications to adapt to using the
memory optimized tables is uh
really a key
a key thing going forward so if
someone's watching this and they're
excited that they can perhaps make their
database and their transactions faster
what do they need to know to know if
this is right for their application
um probably the key the key thing right
off the bat is first of all you don't
have to change your whole application
the more you can understand about where
the performance problems are in your
application where the contention is what
are the most critical tables the most
critical stored procedures those that
information is valuable we have a tool
that can help you analyze that as well
but the starting point is once you're
going to know the areas you need to
optimize uh it starts with converting
one or more of your tables to being
memory optimized and
the key requirement there is it must fit
in memory
if it doesn't fit in memory it's not
eligible right and that's a key point I
think about hackathon well
one of the really distinguishing
features of hackathon compared with
competing products is that we don't
insist that you put all your data in
there absolutely you can keep
your old databases both audio tables
just using this base table and you take
the most performance critical ones and
convert those
right so it's not an All or Nothing
solution you start gradually yes that's
certainly very key to it right so how
did working with a researcher uh impact
the project that you were working on
here uh I think it had a big impact
working with Paul I think one of the key
things he brings to the table is he he
knows how databases have been built the
the research around them the engineering
around them
we work with him early on with the
column store technology and one of the
core things he did was help us
understand how to incorporate it into
SQL server and the the ability to take a
new engine like the column store engine
incorporated into SQL server was kind of
a critical experience for hecaton
because we needed to do the same for it
um
also uh
you have
early experience in hash indexing
technology linear hashing technology yes
uh hashing technology is one of the key
indexing Concepts that that heckington
has
um and probably related to it is even
the ability to to publish the work that
we did jointly you have so much more
experience than the development team and
in publishing it and getting the word
out there about what we've done we've
collaborated on two papers so
that's been very valuable as well well
as you know by now I've been doing now
I've been doing it for what 35 years
where can people go to find out more
about this incredible work that you've
done or if they want to try it for
themselves
well Paul you want to say you can yeah
the research work the research work you
can go to my website uh there's uh
pointers to research papers on that and
so on
and then on the product side there's
much more yeah the development team has
a whole blog series
and we also have the ctp2 SQL 14 ctb2
available for um
download so you can try it out and
right in all the documentation yeah the
application's all on there it's all on
msdn so plenty of information
and so as you move forward what's next
and what are some of the bottlenecks
that keep you from going you know 200
times faster
oh no no no but we still have to get to
100 yeah you gotta you gotta think about
what 100x means going hundredx faster is
that you have to get the same work done
so spending getting rid of 99 of the
work that you tried to do so in in
Computing terms uh you you get rid of 90
99 of the instructions and still get the
work done
that is very difficult
yeah and a hundred times even a hundred
times is uh
you know it's uh it's not 60 miles an
hour it's 6 000 miles an hour and um
uh that's a big enough difference but
but to answer your question uh we
basically want to unlock
the 10 20 even 50x gains for more and
more applications
um and that just involves optimizing uh
some of the areas we didn't optimize uh
and also
the uh the first release doesn't
um
give you the full feature set of SQL
Server when you want to use these memory
optimized tables and for most customers
it's not that they can't get that
they're not satisfied with 10x and they
want us to give them 50. it's that they
can't convert more of their application
easily and they'd rather have more of
their application get 10x
than certain small parts get 50. so
we're going to go after the wider
broader applications right right
it's a version one product
still a lot of work to do yeah that's
for sure
so while you may be referred to as a
grandfather database as you might be a
great grandfather at some point uh I am
a grandfather by calling me my
grandfather or database is that's
pushing in a little bit too much
there are lots of other people's people
that could could us prior to that title
thanks for talking to us today
thank you